last point on this issue of power last
night
a gunman who was dressed as a fedex
delivery man
shot the husband and the son of a
federal judge
esther salas at their new jersey home
killed the sun horrible story
salus was in the basement she was not
injured the shooter couldn't find her
the motive is unknown according to nbc
and abc
this judge was assigned a case on
jeffrey epstein's finances
five days ago is that a coincidence
i don't think this shooting was just a
random incident i don't think you'd
dress up as a fedex delivery man
and go in and target a federal judge and
try to kill her entire family
if it's just a random whoopsie daisy
random
senseless act of killing seems to me a
lot of people around jeffrey epstein
wind up dead including jeffrey epstein
that's just one case one bizarre example
of a place where a lot of powerful
people are connected to this one guy and
things just keep going wrong
it's an example where regardless of what
you think about the whole epstein thing
there's so many theories on what
happened and nobody knows the truth yet
and maybe never will know the truth but
we do know there's a lot of power
there there's a lot of exercises of
power
going on there are some people trying to
exercise power to cover up the truth
there are some people trying to exercise
power
to take away your freedoms there are
some people trying to exercise
power to dismantle your government and
your civilization
same way we say the only way to stop a
bad guy with a gun is a good guy with a
gun the only way to stop
a bad politician exercising political
power
is to have we the people come in and
exercise
political power that's the only way
we're going to do it are we willing to
do it
do we have the will to survive we will
see
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts